welcome back to the David Pacman show I
Am David packman if he was
a giant elf who got stung by a thousand
bees in the neck and then swelled up and
became this monstrosity before you
speaking of monstrosities there's
another unplanned segue I'm becoming
very good at those
Mike Uh Kevin McCarthy not Mike McCarthy
that's a that's a different person who
coaches football Kevin McCarthy Speaker
of the House of Representatives of these
United States there's a lot of words
that come to mind when you think about
Kevin McCarthy Integrity is not one that
comes to mind
intelligent is not one that comes to
mind necessarily
um but uh
sycophantic is and a tool a useful idiot
for Radicals in Congress certainly comes
to mind he was on with Margaret
um Brennan yesterday on Face the Nation
and gave a disastrous
performance just a disastrous interview
with Margaret Brennan
and he was asked many many questions
some of which he he faked like he
answered he has this new thing that he
does when when he's answering a question
with with an answer that isn't an answer
to the actual question he says why man
let me answer your question the way I
say I'm going to answer the question he
he's that's his new tack is to become
like aggressive guy
and he's asked two things we're gonna
play two clips here one is about George
Santos
and about whether or not he should be
expelled from the body because you need
two-thirds of the House of
Representatives to vote to expel him as
a member
they're not going to do that because
they've got a Democrat Governor in New
York a number of different reasons that
are at play here but the other thing
he's asked about is about Marjorie
Taylor green being placed on the coveted
Origins committee to investigate that
the same woman who believes wearing a
mask is like the treatment of the Jews
during the Holocaust
the same woman who calls into question
every sudden death as vaccine linked a
woman who believes 911 was a hoax a
woman who believes Jews have lasers in
space aimed at California to fire a
laser and start a forest fire this is a
woman who has been elevated to the house
oversight committee and others of
importance she went from having no
committees at all
to some of the most elevated and sought
after committee assignments in the
entire house and you you would ask
yourself how is that when she spoke
nothing but poison into the ear of Kevin
McCarthy and about Kevin McCarthy and
all of a sudden their their thick as
thieves their Pals they're taking
selfies together on the floor of the
house
it's a valid question that should be
asked
and it was asked by Margaret Brennan and
this is what took place these These are
members who just got elected by their
constituents and we put them into
committees and I'm proud to do it let me
ask you about some specifics and
um Marjorie Taylor green you put her on
a new subcommittee to investigate the
origins of covet yes she compared mask
requirements to the type of abuse Jews
were subjected to during the Holocaust
she called for fauci to be arrested and
imprisoned and she spread conspiracy
theories how's anyone supposed to take
that work seriously and find that work
credible very well you look at all of it
so you have all the questions out there
I think with the Americans you think
these are legitimate questions I think
with the American public wants to see is
an open dialogue in the process this is
a select committee where people can have
all the questions they want and you'll
see the outcome
um those are nonsense answers from Kevin
McCarthy that we need to all the
questions need to be asked no they don't
not all questions are on the same level
Kevin McCarthy not all questions are
valid of the work of a of a of a special
Select Committee in the House of
Representatives open dialogue we're just
asking questions this is this is the
work of conspiracy theory this is how
they act this is what they say well
we're just asking questions what's wrong
with asking questions
and when you put someone like this as
pernicious and Sinister and indeed
stupid as Marjorie Taylor green on this
committee it diminishes the work that
they will do but again it doesn't matter
to Republicans but they're not in it for
credible findings they're in it for the
theater of it they're in it for the show
of it
now I was going to play this other clip
first but I I chose to do it second and
that is his absolute refusal to answer
the question about getting rid of George
Santos or what they're going to do at
all instead he starts talking about
proxy voting and the house being broken
and when she forces him or tries
attempts to make a force to him to
answer the question
he's not having it he's doing that thing
that I talked about earlier
watch this
but doesn't it further wear down
credibility when you put someone who's
under State local Federal and
international investigation as a
representative
I'm talking about George Santos
representative from New York we should
have that discussion so let's have that
discussion you want to bring up Santos
and let's talk about the institution
itself because I agree wholeheartedly
that Congress is broken and I think you
I think your listeners or viewers should
understand what proxy voting was because
it never took place but I'm asking about
George Santos I know you asked me a
question let me ask you because you
could put it to a vote you asked me a
question I'd appreciate if you let me
answer so let's go through this because
it's not one simple answer Congress is
broken based upon what is transpired in
the last Congress the American public
wasn't able to come in to see us
people voted by proxy meaning you didn't
have to show up for work bills didn't go
have to go through committee so what I'm
trying to do is open the people's house
back for the people so their voice is
there so people are held accountable so
now as I just had in the last week for
the first time in seven years every
member got through it if you got a third
of your caucus to vote to ask him you
could do so do you don't think you could
get your Republicans to do that I wasn't
finished answering the question so if
every single new person brought into
Congress was elected by their
constituents what their constituents
have done has lend their voice to the
American public so those members can all
serve on committee now what I'm trying
to do is change some of these committees
as well like the Intel committee is
different than you're just not going to
answer the question I asked well no I no
you don't get to question whether I
answer it you ask the question I'm
trying to get I don't think you've said
the name George Santos like once
but you know what I'm talking about
prophecies but no you started the
question with Congress was broken and I
agreed with you but I was answering the
question of how Congress is broken and
how we're changing it so if I can finish
the question that you asked me how
Congress has broken I equated every
single member they just got elected by
their by their constituents they have a
right to serve so that means that Santos
can serve on a committee the same way
swalwell who had a relationship with a
Chinese spy but they will not serve on
Intel control room because well that's
unfortunate I wish I could answer the
question I would love to have you back I
would love to be able to come back and
have time to answer the question
not smart listen there are skilled
politicians who are very Adept at doing
the thing that Kevin McCarthy wishes he
could do which is you're asked a
question and you answer an entirely
different question and then it just
moves on
he's not good at it instead he gets
called out blatantly overt like well
you're just not going to answer the
question then and he doesn't he
filibusters for for just about two
minutes in that space
refusing to answer the easiest of
questions
and you know what it's going to catch
him because George Santos and all the
investigations that are taking place
relative to financial impropriety to
campaign Finance impropriety it's going
to come back and his innocent until
proven guilty thing isn't going to play
anymore
when George Santos eventually
possibly
gets convicted of these crimes and they
are crimes some of the things that he's
being accused of now it's not just he
lied about his mom dying on 911 as
Despicable as that is it's not just
lying about being a volleyball star with
replaced knees
there are serious issues that Kevin
McCarthy isn't qualified isn't capable
and has no desire to try to get to the
bottom of one of our sponsors is Helix
sleep I have been sleeping on a helix
mattress at home for years now I
couldn't be more happy with it I
recommend it to everybody the other day
even though she's not allowed in the big
bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warrant guarantee unlike
many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you are
supporting good jobs Helix sleep is
giving my audience 350 off plus two free
pillows this is the place to get pillows
you know what I mean go to
helixsleep.com Pacman and use code Helix
partner the link is down below